oh and there's another way to make sense
mmm and let me figure out what that is
doesn't mean we have all the answers and
I'm sure as hell no I don't and I don't
think you think you do either but we're
at least giving them a little room to
figure it out and it's pretty cool well
the thing about Peterson that's been
fascinating is how many people
misrepresent what he says to try to
frame him him in a way that makes him
evil and makes their position seem more
ethical or more moral or better or more
intellectual there's so many articles
being written about him almost on a
daily basis
he didn't misrepresent what he's saying
it's epic [ __ ] I mean weird that's
all it is these guys want clicks that's
all they want I mean I've we've done
about 20 shows in the last six weeks or
so bounced around from Nashville and
Houston and Atlanta and Chicago and
everywhere else the crowds have been
incredible it's it's probably split you
know first off they're always go well
it's angry white men that's the main
thing it's all angry white men now first
off let's say it was all angry white men
there that in and of itself doesn't mean
it's bad let's say there was like a
really disaffected group of angry white
men that really felt like either
masculinity had been compromised or they
couldn't get jobs or they didn't feel
good about their lives like if there was
someone talking to them that was helping
them that would actually be good but
let's just put that aside right because
they don't mean it in a positive way so
they say it's all angry women now I can
tell you it's about 60/40 male to female
roughly at Jordan shows at Jordan shows
yeah and it's do you think that's like
dates that reluctantly go along with men
like there are some I mean there will be
guys that well is actually usually girls
will come up to me after and they'll go
you know he's a big fan of you guys or
he loves Jordan or he loves you or blah
blah blah and I'm just here but then
they all have a great time I mean I'm
telling you this thing has been an
insane love fest I know you saw the
video that Jordan posted last night it
was his birthday last night we were at
where the hell was I Lanta the
tabernacle in Atlanta you know almost
3,000 people singing happy birthday to
him we brought out this freaking stuffed
lobster and a piece of meat because he's
on this crazy meat diet now and it's
like it's an endless love fest every
street we walk down people high-five and
I say and I we did a little
meet-and-greet impromptu thing at the
Lincoln Memorial and about a hundred
people showed up just out of nowhere
it's like these people are just trying
to figure [ __ ] out they're not white
supremacists they're not all right they
don't hate women
it is literally nothing that they say
because they want clicks and the way
they get clicks I mean you know the way
they go clicks is they say the absolute
reverse from the truth it's not that
they lie a little bit like a little lie
I think nobody would even picked up on
it we don't think that's what they do I
think they're just misrepresenting I
don't think they're saying the apps the
opposite of the truth they're just they
just look they're finding these little
categories like homophobia transphobia
homophobe he's on tour with the gay guy
trans folk there are trans people that
show up there and I and I discussed it
with him every freaking night I asked
you know we do it so I basically do like
15 minutes to stand up up top he does an
hour and a half and then we do a QA
together and we bring out all of these
things and every night to clear it up
and sometimes I'll have people bust out
their phones and I'll be like why don't
you guys record this tonight let's get
it out on Twitter where he takes down
the all right because he hates the
identity politics of the right as much
as the identity politics of the left I
mean I don't know I think the reason we
all focus on the thing of the left